Міла кинула навчання у Великобританії і вже понад два місяці
разом із багатьма іншими болгарами мітингує за майбутнє Болгарії -
майбутнє без корупції і олігархів.
Мені знадобилося кілька років, щоб усвідомити:
моє рішення поїхати з країни, можливо,
було не найкращим, але таким, що робиш із безвиході.
Міла спершу хотіла просто насолодитися літом на батьківщині,
але коли вона повернулася з Шотландії, розпочалися протести проти корупції,
тож Міла та її друзі вирішили не повертатися назад.
Вони щодня виходять на вулиці і протестують проти "радянщини",
якої ще досі чимало в їхній країні.
Гадаю, однією з головних проблем є те, що ми досі не позбулися
свого минулого та залишків тоталітарного режиму.
Наш прем'єр-міністр був охоронцем останнього тоталітарного лідера.
Протести розпочалися на початку липня. Головна вимога демонстрантів:
прем'єр-міністр і генеральний прокурор мають піти у відставку.
Їх звинувачують у корупції та зв’язках з олігархами.
Болгарський прем’єр Бойко Борисов фактично править країною
з незначними перервами з 2009 року. За даними Transparency International,
Болгарія вже багато років вважається найбільш корумпованою країною в ЄС.
Оглядачі вважають, що в Брюсселі на це заплющують очі,
бо Борисов грає роль такого собі "доброго" європейця
щодо врегулювання міграційного кризи в ЄС,
розробки єдиної енергетичної політики чи боротьби з коронавірусом.
Водночас, запевняють правозахисники, Борисов, по суті,
"розтоптав" свободу слова в країні, а фонди ЄС
перетворив на своєрідну "крамницю самообслуговування"
для своїх друзів-однопартійців та олігархів.
У Болгарії регулярно вибухають корупційні скандали,
і майже ніхто не несе відповідальності за розкрадання коштів.
Тому мітингувальники й вимагають відставки уряду
та проведення нових виборів у країні. У столиці Софії
люди встановили намети і загородження на великих дорожніх перехрестях,
але поліція знесла їх після зіткнень із демонстрантами.
Дехто кидав у поліцейських димові шашки, каміння і пляшки.
Ситуація ще більш загострилася після того, як була спроба
прорвати поліцейське оточення біля будівлі парламенту.
Поліція застосувала сльозогінний газ та шумові гранати.
Десятки людей потрапили у лікарні з опіками та симптомами задухи.
У болгарській поліції заперечують звинувачення правозахисників
у неспівмірному застосуванні сили. Правоохоронці запевняють, що
наметове містечко, яке мітингувальники називали "зоною свободи",
було схованкою для піротехнічних пристроїв і важких предметів,
якими кидали в охорону парламенту.
Організатори ж протестів звинуватили у заворушеннях провокаторів.
Аби загалодити конфлікт, правляча партія пропонує змінити конституцію.
Я думаю, що реформа судової влади однозначно необхідна.
Я повторюю: це вимагає конституційних змін.
Ми заявили про свою підтримку цього процесу місяць тому.
Болгарський прем’єр заявив, що готовий залишити свою посаду,
якщо парламент вирішить скликати Великі народні збори -
орган, що матиме повноваження ухвалити поправки до конституції країни.
Серед запропонованих владою змін -
скорочення кількості депутатів парламенту з 240 до 120,
реформа судової влади, а також посилення підзвітності прокурорів і суддів.
Однак ексміністр юстиції Хрісто Іванов, який протестує з першого дня,
як і більшість мітингувальників, не вірить владі.
Їхні дії роблять генерального прокурора ще менш підзвітним.
Отже, вони роблять прямо протилежне тому, про що просять люди.
Це відсутність діалогу. Люди говорять дуже чітко, чого вони хочуть.
Вони очікуть підзвітності генерального прокурора,
а уряд робить все навпаки. А потім вони кажуть: чому немає діалогу?
Діалогу немає, тому що ви корумповані, тому що
ви робите протилежне і тому що вам потрібно йти геть.
За даними опитувань, близько 60 відсотків болгар підтримують акції протесту.
Для Міли це добра новина. Але навіть якби підтримка скоротилася,
вона все одно б продовжувала боротися.
Я буду тут. Деякі з моїх близьких друзів, родичів -
ми всі так вирішили. Можливо, нас буде не так багато,
але поступово, починаючи з нуля, ми зміцніємо.
Люди сподіваються, що протести, які тривають вже понад два місяці,
таки поборють корупцію і олігархію.
Для Міли це означатиме ще більше: віднайти свою покинуту батьківщину.